- Hi, my name's Audrey.
- And I'm Chloe.
- And we're 7 years old
and today two chefs are gonna be competing
to make our dream outer space dish.
- [Audrey and Chloe] 3, 2, 1, blast off
- [Rie and Alix] Hi!
- I'm Rie.
- And I'm Alix. I have a question for you.
- What?
- If you were going to a
birthday party on Mars,
what food would you wanna eat?
- I would maybe drink a outer space drink.
It's purple and has little
pieces of stars in it.
Makes you go a little crazy.
- Oh!
- I'm drawing a Flower Planet.
- What do you like to eat?
- I like to eat donuts.
- What are the best flavors
on the Flower Planet?
- Strawberry. Lavender.
- Lavender. Do you like
vanilla and chocolate too?
- Yeah, I love chocolate and vanilla,
but she loves chocolate more.
- The picture is very creative
so I'm excited to be creative as well.
- The next thing I'm gonna
draw is the Ice Cream Planet.
Stars taste delicious
since they make wishes.
- [Rie And Alix] Oh!
- It's a cookie that
has little stars on it
and it's a big star after stars are on.
- What does it taste like?
- It tastes like a normal cookie
but in the middle there will be a filling.
- Have you eaten a star before?
- No.
- No?
- Yes.
- Oh, you did?
- Are you excited for a space party?
- [Audrey and Chloe] Yeah!
- How about we wish upon
a star and then blast off?
So...
- [Everyone] 3, 2, 1. Blast off!
- Woo! Are you ready?
- I am. Are you?
- I've always wanted to go to space, so...
- I'm not interested.
- Really? They say there's
two kinds of people.
People who wanna go to deep sea,
and people who wanna go to deep space.
- I don't wanna go either.
(Alix laughs)
- Gonna take some risks
today, but you know what?
We're in space.
- Yeah.
- So...
- We're gonna just have fun.
- Always.
- Aww!
- I draw your cookies back.
Yay! Champ is here.
- As always, I am so excited
to do this show with Rie
and to get to cook alongside
her like old times.
- I'm going to start with Ice Cream Planet
'cause I need some prep time.
- I'm gonna start with Flower Planet.
Listen, in this competition,
I am not above picnics
or food coloring as we know.
- Yeah.
- These are kids.
- Their taste buds is very sensitive.
- Yes.
- So they don't like complicated flavor.
- I do wonder if I'm at a disadvantage now
in this competition because Rie is a mom.
- I feel more confident
after I have a child,
but at the same time,
my son is the pickiest boy in the world.
- I still think of myself
as a child, though,
so maybe I can relate to
the judges a little better.
- I'm scooping ice cream
and making a sphere.
- I'm gonna bake my cake on a sheet tray,
just 'cause I want it to bake faster.
I need a pretty good volume of cakes,
so I'm just gonna make another one
and put it right back on here.
- I got a bunch of different fruits
and I'm gonna start cutting.
- Rie has been making things from scratch
with a lot of natural ingredients.
At first I was a little intimidated,
but then I remembered
that the judges are kids,
so I know my audience.
I'm just gonna try to
make it kind of galaxy-ish
by just putting a little
black, a little blue.
Oh! A lot of purple. This looks cool.
- It's like a galaxy.
- Swirly galaxy. Rie, do
you wanna go to space?
- I don't.
- Why?
- I love ours.
We have to make sure ours
doesn't fall apart and--
- You're right.
- We don't need to go.
- You should stay.
- What do you do in space?
- Just chill, you know, vibe.
- You can chill in a beach.
You have to drink your own urine.
- No you don't.
- No. I went to NASA and it's--
- Oh, you went to NASA now!
(Rie laughs)
I wholeheartedly believe in aliens.
- I don't need to go out to seek aliens.
They can come to me.
- Yeah.
- And see me.
- I was at the Hollywood Bowl last night
and I swear I saw you up front.
- She was explaining what happened,
but it's just over my head.
- My swirly galaxy cake is ready to bake.
- I'm using this pineapple
for the galaxy drink.
- As you can see, I'm back
on another box of cake mix.
- Alix is using a lot
of store-bought stuff.
I think it is actually a good strategy
because kids loved sweet stuff.
- This time I'm going to
add a little bit less liquid
because I'm going to do a hack
where you use cake mix
to make cookie dough.
This is for the star cookie.
- So I'm now cutting mango.
- I love mango.
- Do you wanna eat?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Remember the good old tasty days--
- Yeah!
- Where you would feed me all the time?
- We sat next to each other.
- At first I think you were like,
"Oh God, who is this girl
sitting next to me? Can I move?"
(Rie laughs)
And then at some point
you just accepted it.
- That's not how I remember, but okay.
(Alix laughs)
- I have these neon mixed
sprinkles. They're little stars.
- I remember you are always so fast.
- I'll be making a lot of mistakes
and I need the extra time.
- Once there was a story called
"The Tortoise and the Hare."
- I just try to work fast because I know
there's gonna be a point
where I mess something up.
So I wanna leave myself extra
time for that to happen.
- Now I'm going to make star cookie.
- I'm gonna be moving on
to my Ice Cream Planets.
I have these fun Cookie
Crunch Blue Ice Cream
and this one is Mermaid Sparkle Ice Cream.
I need it patchier, 'cause the Earth,
it's green and blue swirl.
- Oh! I added egg into my butter mixture
and I'm gonna sift in flour.
- In my mind, this was an amazing idea.
In reality, it's fine.
(Rie and Alix laugh)
- My cookie dough is done,
so I'm going to put this
in the refrigerator.
- Woosh!
- Woah!
- My cake is baked.
- That's so cool!
- I'm just gonna start
tearing this into pieces.
I really wanna go larger
than life with my dish today.
So I'm thinking some sort of
giant cake pop as a planet.
Go to space or go home.
(Rie laughs)
- I'd go home.
I am going to make base of Flower Planet
and I have tofu, I have Mochiko.
- Oh! Mochi donna?
- Yeah and squeeze some lemon juice.
- Rie is pulling out tofu.
If we're supposed to be
providing nutritional value
to these kids, then I'm going to lose.
- I wanna win, but I also don't
want to give too much sugar.
- I have this Space Blue Vanilla Frosting.
Again, I haven't made
a giant cake pop ever
so this is definitely not going on a stick
like a normal cake pop would.
But I'm gonna try to maneuver
some sort of stand for it.
- So can you still call it cake pop?
- This is kind of more
difficult than I imagined.
It kind of breaks apart.
Because this cake pop is so massive,
its weight is kind of crushing on itself.
- How about using plastic wrap?
(Alix gasps)
Good idea?
- But Rie gave me a really
genius tip to use plastic wrap,
which really helps me
get that sphere shape.
- I'm just kneading my donut dough
until everything is smooth.
I'm going to rest it in the refrigerator
and I'm going to roll out my cookie dough.
Just cut out star.
- Can I have some dough?
- Yeah, are you gonna eat?
- Do you not like cookie dough?
- I don't eat cookie dough.
I think it's America thing.
- You don't eat cookie dough?
- No.
- It's so good.
She has this shooting star
coming out of her drink,
so I figured it would be
cool to do a sugar one.
I was just gonna use a Jolly Rancher
and melt it down so it
would fit in the star.
We only had a very small
metal star cookie cutter
so I realized that my Jolly Rancher
wouldn't quite fit inside it.
Rie suggested that I smash
it with the rolling pin.
(Alix gasps, Rie laughs)
Those suckers are hard.
Who knew that Jolly
Ranchers were so dangerous?
Okay, I'm gonna put some of
my Jolly Rancher shrapnel
in here and I just wanted
to melt down into its star.
- So I'm going to cut out
rice paper in a flower shape.
This rice paper flower, I saw on TikTok
and it looked easy enough.
It's very difficult to cut. It's breaking.
- Rie is so talented
and I'm not used to
seeing her make mistakes
but she's kind of struggling
with the rice paper flowers.
I wish I could help you here
but I don't know what you're doing.
I'm gonna use edible flowers
for this reason. Easy enough.
- How about that? Does
it look like flower?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- It's like a star
flower, which is perfect.
- Yeah. From here I think I
can kind of trim into a circle.
This is becoming a craft, not cooking.
- Now I'm moving on
finally to my mirror glaze.
I have my gelatin sheet
and they need to bloom
I'm gonna add in water, sugar
and sweetened condensed milk.
And I'm gonna grab my gelatin
and squeeze out all of the extra water.
Feels like a dead jellyfish.
Pop this into my sugar
mixture so it can dissolve.
Now I'm gonna pour my hot mixture
over this broken-up white chocolate,
and I want it to be hot enough
for it to melt the
chocolate along with it.
Blend up the white
chocolate into my mixture.
So the galaxy mirror glaze is something
that's really finicky and hard to do.
I know that from experience
but I just want to go for it today.
I think this might work.
- I'm gonna make small donuts
and I'm gonna make two big donuts
so I have some safety net.
I'm going to make mochi
for my Ice Cream Planet.
I add Mochiko and sugar
and I'm lightly mixing, add water, mix.
Now I'm going to microwave this
until it becomes sticky and stretchy.
- So I've separated my mirror glaze
into five different bowls
and I'm just gonna be coloring
them different variations
from black to blue to purple to pink.
- My cookie is a little softer
and I'm cutting inside
with another star shape.
My cookie is out from the oven
and I'm going to stuff with gummy bear.
My mochi came out from the
microwave. I'm gonna add color.
Hope this was a good idea
that's gonna look cute.
And be very careful when
you're making mochi.
- Sticky!
- It's so sticky and it's very, very hot.
You have to be very
careful. Roll this mochi.
You have to use a bunch of
corn starch, potato starch.
You also have to do it
while it's hot. Wow, look!
- That is beautiful.
- Yay! Thank you.
I have ice cream and I'm
going to just rub this.
- I have my cake planet
out. Good as it's gonna get.
My glaze is at temperature.
I'm gonna pour each of
these into the other.
This is chaotic. Okay, I'm gonna
pour this on. Wish me luck.
Choosing to do the galaxy mirror glaze
was a big risk I took in this competition.
I think that's the
quietest I've ever been.
Now I'm just gonna pour a
bunch of white food coloring
and I'm just gonna take a
paintbrush and kind of flick it.
- So I'm just trying to wrap
my mochi around the ice cream,
but it started melting, so
I have to move very quickly
and kind of twist on the bottom.
So close the bottom and
put it on the ice cream.
And I'm gonna freeze this again.
- I hope it doesn't fall off.
Maybe I should transfer it to a plate.
(Rie claps)
Oh gosh. Okay, it's
going in the fridge now.
- I'm going to fry this rice
paper. Hope it works. Oh no!
When I was trying to fry the
rice paper, it was curling up
and it doesn't look like flour at all.
The second one, I was also hoping
it's gonna keep the shape, but it doesn't.
So I think hopefully this is
gonna work using two spiders
and I'm going to press lightly.
- Is it working?
- I think.
- Oh.
- Yes! Nice. I was able
to make flower shape.
- I'm happy with my star
cookies. They came out cute.
So I'm just gonna take
the inside of the cookie
and carefully just put
this marshmallow fluff
right in the middle and
clean up the star shape.
Next thing I made my star Jolly Rancher,
and I'm not exactly sure
how I'm gonna get this out
of the cookie cutter.
Unfortunately, I forgot
to put any cooking spray
or oil on the cookie cutter.
We had a heat gun that I was able to use.
I've never used one of these before.
It's always a great thing to say.
Okay, well this heat gun
works really quickly.
I also sprayed it with cooking spray
to hopefully get it easier to remove.
It actually ended up burning the oil.
It's not looking great in
there, so that didn't work.
I think what I'm gonna do
is heat up my Jolly Ranchers
in a sauce pan and loosen
them up until they're liquid.
I have to move really quickly.
I'm gonna pour it into
the lined cookie cutter
and then also just streak
it on the baking sheet
to create the shooting
effect, like a woosh.
And this actually ended up working.
Oddly enough, the green Jolly Rancher
turned this brown color,
but it kind of looks
like a gold star, so I'm gonna go with it
- Now I'm gonna fry donna.
It looks pretty good.
I'm just coloring this white
flower with food coloring.
Sprinkle apple, sugar, have a taste.
Mhmm! Doesn't have any flavor.
I melted white chocolate and coconut oil,
added very little food color,
and this is the glaze for my donut.
My cookie is stuck, so I'll
put it back in the oven.
- Is that the gummy bear?
- Yeah.
- Like a trampoline.
- Yeah. That's it.
- It works!
- It became yellow, but it's kind of cool.
It just became very
gooey. Goo in a cookie.
- Woo! Wow! It's cool.
- Yeah, it's like plastic.
I'm not happy with it.
- I'm going to use donuts
on the plate under my Ice Cream Planet.
It's kind of like Saturn rings.
We have this cool luster spray
so I was gonna kind of
spray them silver and gold.
Gold leaf just to be, you know, fancy.
- The last thing I have to
make is the galaxy juice.
I have pineapple, mango and strawberry.
Put some sugar 'round
the rim like margarita.
- Margarita!
- Say when I have a
drink, makes you crazy.
- Crazy!
- I'm giving them what they
want. I'm making milkshake.
- My idea for the drink is to make
a sort of slushie vibes.
I kind of wanted like a
color changing galaxy vibe.
So I'm gonna flavor lemonade
with Kool-Aid packets.
- I'm putting pineapple
and I put a little bit
of food color, mango.
I have Ube Ice Cream.
- And we blended up some
ice spoon into my glass.
Spray paint this. Woo!
- My drink is done.
God, maybe I have shake in my teeth.
Not sure these cookies are a good idea,
so I'm gonna just hide
it with other cookies.
- For the flower of my Flower Planet,
I got these edible flowers
that I thought are really cute.
- I have waffle cone and
I have extra flowers.
I'm going to put this on top
and then I'm going to
put my mochi ice cream.
- I think I'm gonna plate them
both just so they both have a cookie
- Filling the blank space
with some sprinkles.
- My shooting star has set.
I'm gonna try to peel this off. Oh, shoot.
The shooting star is
giving me a lot of trouble
which is a little bit surprising.
I thought it'd be one of the
easier elements for my plate
but I'm just gonna set
it on top of the drink.
- Dust off my ice cream. I'm done.
How about you?
- I'm done.
May the best astronaut win.
I'm actually really surprised
that I was able to pull all
of my components off because I
was winging this total thing.
I think the galaxy juice will
taste good, but I'm a little
worried that it's kind of
just melded into one color.
Flower Planet I think
is the star of the show.
The mirror glaze set
perfectly on the cake pop.
Ice Cream Planet is looking pretty good.
I really love how I chose to
spray paint those donuts gold.
I also really like how the
star cookie turned out.
I think it looks a lot like
the picture and I really hope
that they like the filling inside.
I really hope I win this one.
I think it's some of my
best work on the shelf.
- Overall, I'm so happy how it turned out.
I love my galaxy mochi ice cream.
It just looked like a little
planet, Flower Planet.
It looks like blossom alien flowers.
The galaxy drink it is perfectly swirled.
It looks like Milky Way.
The yellow star cookie.
Even I hide it underneath
the little cookie
with white chocolate, looks really pretty.
I hope I win.
- [Audrey And Chloe] We're
ready to see the feast.
- Oh my gosh.
- What?
- I recognize the Flower Planet.
That's the Ice Cream Planet, Audrey.
- Well, it does not look like our picture.
- What, is this oils?
- What flavor is this?
- A donut! A gold donut.
- I wanna eat this all day.
- Nice.
- Audrey, let's try the star cookie.
- I really like this. What is it?
- (inaudible) But the
cookie tastes amazing.
- It tastes really, really good.
- I do not like the filling.
- Is that jell-o?
- Oh! It's cake!
- It's so soft.
- Audrey has picked a couple
things that she doesn't like
on my plate, so I'm getting
a little bit worried.
- I just ate a flower.
I like the space color.
Audrey, it feels like we
should go crazy right now.
This is already like lemonade.
I'm scared you're gonna go crazy.
Try it! Try it!
- It just tastes like lemonade.
For my picture, I did not draw this.
- Damn, they are some harsh critics.
- I really like the Flower Planet.
They did the Flower Planet really well.
- Yes!
- It's literally gold.
Oh my God. I'm rich.
I'm gonna skip dinner.
- I'm skipping dinner.
- I hate to say it but I
really think I got this one.
- Oh my goodness, is this plastic?
- And this, I do not recognize.
- Did I just eat plastic?
- Audrey said my flower
tastes like plastic.
I should have heavily seasoned that.
- I recognize this.
That's the Ice Cream Planet.
- The Ice Cream Planet.
It's not strawberry flavored,
but I really like it.
It's time to go crazy. It's ice cream!
- My mission completed.
She wanted crazy drink and
I made her crazy dance.
- Yeah, the flavor now, I really like it.
- Yes. I love the ice
cream, except the tree part.
- This is the best day of my life.
The bread is a little bit too hot.
It does not look like my picture, Chloe.
I don't really like--
- You're going too harsh, Audrey.
They were good, but I didn't
like the whipped creams.
I only like the cooking.
Wait what?
- It has honey on it.
Just sticky.
- This is really hard to decide.
- So they seem like they
enjoyed Alex dish more,
so I'm losing my confidence.
- Hi Chloe, hi Audrey.
- Good to see you again.
- Did you guys enjoy?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, we really did.
- Did you so much fun, are you crazy?
- Yeah!
- Did you like the space
dish from chef 1 or chef 2?
We're gonna say it on 3...
- [Rie and Alix] 2, 1...
- [Audrey and Chloe] 2!
(Rie squeals)
- That's mine! I won!
- Listen, I'm always so happy for Rie.
I love her and I am so happy
that she won, but damn it!
- Congratulations Rie.
- Thank you so much!
- We have a present for you. Alix.
- [Rie and Alix] Oh my God.
- Thank you.
This is so cute.
You wrote a little letter.
Honestly, this letter, it
feels like a consolation prize.
It makes it all worth it.
Wow, how beautiful, you guys are artists.
You have to do one more thing.
3, 2, 1...Blast off!
(upbeat music)